hello welcome to the lobby gamespot's
weekly hang out every tuesday at two
p.m. pacific right here on gamespot com
how you doing I'm Daniel Dwyer joined by
scott Butterworth and Andy bellman still
taking notes such as the professionalism
we have on offer here is just doodling
I'm just looking at me nothing it's just
because I don't talk a bad game with
under embargo we can get through this
whole show without mention doing jobs on
cars you know what game is not your
embargo that we're here to talk about
though didn't you ever see where's
getting right into it yeah true that
banter was going right for the need for
speed yeah it's a game it's just gold
need for speed right it's just called
leapers being how does the closest need
for speed it is too though in relation
to the old need for speed games sure uh
it's kind of like underground ok so the
need for speed underground games were
like the tuner street racing kind of
games and this came out in 2003-2004 I
believe if it's not it's not exactly
like those games but it is sort of about
you know tuner culture again and it's
about any illegal street racing and here
it's always nighttime you're building up
your own tutor mobi own so it's similar
to those but an extra fields like
driving wise and mechanically feels a
lot like hot pursuit actually oh really
we're most wanted I think either of
those it's definitely not shift it's not
like the realistic need for speed but
those were their own thing and it's not
even too much like rivals which was the
first need for speed from coast games
most made this need for speed so you
gave an 80 to 10 on gay spots the review
is currently up right now it's true I am
talk a little bit about the sort of the
the the time you hit a wall because I
find that to be an interesting part of
your review you kind of tried to make a
you know master of all trades or a jack
of all trades master of none car and
didn't quite work out yeah exactly i
mean at that and that's exactly what
happened i was actually kind of
struggling with how to start the review
and what i wanted to talk about and then
i realized that the moment that sort of
stuck out to me was was that realization
of even though i had some serious
trouble with a difficulty spike late in
the game I still wanted to play I mean
once I got past that and the game became
fun again so great this is you know and
ultimately that's that sort of what
decided the score for me I mean even
when I sat down to write the review I
was kind of torn between a seven and an
eight you know for a lot of the reasons
that I'm sure we're going to get into
but ultimately why I decided on an eight
was me two things want a lot of the
problems that people have at the game
are arguably fleeting stuff that's only
going to affect
small portion of the game and stuff
that's really good is going to continue
to be good things like the driving and
the customization things like that those
would be good in perpetuity but the
other big thing was like I said I always
wanted to keep playing I mean no matter
what I came up against in the game I was
always excited to continue driving to
continue upgrading my vehicle and and
any game that can do that even if I if I
want to go play game after I'm done
reviewing it that's a powerful thing so
in spite of its foibles it still brought
you back exactly what were you doing
when you came back what type of
activities do you sort of what is the
meat and potatoes in newps be sure it's
a little all over the place um you know
there's drift events there's racing
events there's Gymkhana which combines
like a lot of different driving
disciplines and it's you know it's an
open-world structured game kind of like
burnout paradise or you know any number
of previous need for speed games so you
can just pick and choose the events you
like and kind of do those and eventually
you will kind of be forced to do a
little of everything if you want to
continue to progress through the story
but it's pretty open you have a lot of
options actually this one of things I
really wanted to talk about one of the
biggest problems people head but the
game was rubber banding AI which is kind
of a dirty word and when it comes to
racing games and something that is all
too frequent and you know it comes up a
lot in racing games right and it is a
problem it is annoying and I'm bummed
that this game has pretty obvious rubber
banding but here's the thing one it
didn't completely ruin the experience
and to it only affects a small portion
of the events in the game I mean a lot
of the events you're competing against a
clock or trying to reach a point total
things like that only a small handful
have you competing directly against AI
competitors so the rubber banding AI
doesn't affect the entire game it just
affects a small portion and yeah it
sucks that it's there but for me I was
able to work through and get past it
yeah we noticed some of that when we
were we did our gang swap plays yes all
right now playing last week that was fun
it was a good as good luck stream it was
good fun Andy did you place after you we
did that live stream like what is your
sore main takeaway from Newsbeat as
somebody who plays like a bunch of the
fort's a game coming from that sort of
angle yeah i mean like point-blank you
should play forza horizon 2 but like
it's a very different game it's yeah but
it's like it's got all this stuff in it
anymore so it's like I don't know but
the thing about need for speed is we
were playing on xbox one yes one thing
to note is like the ps4 version was
running way smoother the whole like real
and it almost like was catching mind
certain places of the world
better right so I don't know if how much
of a like widespread thing that is or if
there's a patch that fixes that day one
but like that's something to look out
for things we did have like pretty
frequent framerate hitch oh yeah the
xbox one and not that it was like
completely unplayable or I'm table but
it was definitely like a noticeable
thing and that's a that's a key thing
but yeah I would agree like it's not bad
but there's nothing terrible that's
gonna turn you off about it and the
rubber banding AI actually uh is nice in
a way because like on these street race
stuff the streets are empty yeah because
they kind of took out of the traffic
which is nice for the gameplay aspect
because you don't want to run into
random cars like which does happen
sometimes but yeah if it was happening
all the time you would just break your
disc attack like the crew that happens
all the time and you just want to kill
you yeah cuz it's not your fault it's
yeah it comes up also Anderson why why
would you put some in a muter so any
like the drift events like you're saying
it doesn't matter yeah and also like it
helps cuz you get drift trains if you
kind of like sync your drift with all
your dudes yeah and it's all about the
style like you're not racing against
them you're racing like with them to
like put down the best you know drift
turns on the on the switch 'back e turns
of the the mountain is it sounds like
yeah it's it's probably cool kids call
us what's your back you can switch Eve a
key and that in tuner culture that's the
I think yeah sure and tune as a video
yeah okay go for Jeff yeah yeah like one
of the things we both kind of we're
talking about that we liked is it forces
you to tune your car and it gives you
the like the meta slider it just says
gift grip or drift if you want to ignore
everything just there's a master slider
at the very top that like do you want a
grippy card you want to drift gardeners
and you don't think about anything yeah
but I would sincerely recommend diving
into the more like granular things that
you can adjust you can kind of see how
it's green right there yeah handbrake
strength in spring stiffness and like
all this up actually matters it will
impact the way the game controls so if
you are playing the game like I hate how
this handles go with just stuff like it
handles the way you want it to handle
just go mess with it and make it into
what you want it to be yeah I was
interesting you tuned your car
differently and they did a drift event
and it was like a no-go oh yeah I got to
redo this yeah it took me like an
embarrassingly long time to figure that
out and like I said the game almost
encourages you to just build up a single
car like the way the progression system
is structured and
the rate at which currency is meted out
it really encourages you to build up one
car early on at least and so later when
I hit the wall that you had mentioned
earlier basically what happened was I
could no longer get away with having one
car I needed to have multiple cars or at
least drastically retuned my car for
each different event which was a giant
pain by the way it's better to have two
cars if you can afford it did you ever
get the Ferrari f40 because there's
nothing like that oh yeah i bought the
I'm not gonna say it Reich's and used to
reading it that the Lamborghini
Aventador okay it's like the second
highest rated car in the game but I
preferred it over the highest rated and
yeah like once you have enough money you
can buy the crazy exotic cars like
they're absolutely in the game but
really it's about building up your stock
like nothing car into something really
cool and that's a little more rewarding
okay okay let's talk about I feel like
we talked about this couple of weeks ago
when we had you on with guitar hero yes
FMV man hey it's back in a big TV movie
I think cameras have gotten good this is
like a camera nerd thing yeah yeah but I
think like cameras have gotten so good
that they can run these like deep focal
length lenses Minn dot and make it like
lit in a way that's not like super over
the top and a lift coming kind of
natural like it's obviously supplemented
you can you can see hm is going through
windows in this game and stuff but like
it looks nice like I think it's cool and
it's like impressive that they do these
things they have like yeah probably like
you know use motion tracking in the
shots like robotic tracking or or it's
just a steady really good steady camera
like it like it's so impressive it looks
like a key but a good kind of good right
yeah and it's there obviously shooting
like you know Ultra HD like 4k 5k 16 so
it's like Dan this stuff is like but
then the acting is like yeah I didn't
talk about the the camera nerd aspect of
it was really fascinating talking to
Andy about it cuz like that's kind of
what he does those I have even it
occurred to me that the way it was made
was actually kind of cool because yeah I
was more fixated on like the acting and
dialogue which are not great um Ben
guitar hero it was like really
insufferable and just like you i don't
know like I just I really couldn't stand
it in guitar hero but for whatever
reason it really grew on me here I think
because it's just kind of like friendly
and goofy and really well
in a weird way and it just kind of won
me over like it's there's no discernible
plot like there's no like arching
storyline there's nothing in to
comprehend it's like a bunch of people
meeting who are probably are all these
street car racers kind never meeting
near cars like oh yeah exactly like this
brings having that happens in with like
carbs present everything else is like ah
maybe there's a car in the background
but it's like we're shooting outdoors
expensive yeah exactly they needed sets
and then when they did try to bring like
the models of the in-game cars into the
shots you can really see the seams of
the green bits yeah yeah the green
screen so i mean like i said it's it won
me over and it's like charming cam penis
and and I wasn't gonna really penalize
the game too deeply even if it was bad
because to racing game like I'm not
really playing racing games for story
like I just and you can skip everything
by the way if you really are grossed out
by the idea of FM vs you can absolutely
just skip everything in it you still get
all the same events you can still play
the game exactly the same so you don't
have to experience any of that but if
you sit through it it might win you over
like it won me over because it is just
like goofy and fun and like you just get
to know and love these stupid characters
say I actually grew to really enjoy
which is kind of like what need for
speed underground was as well it was
this like dumb like character like it
that's kind of in fitting with it in a
way so I mainly just remember like
underglow and all that kind of stuff
that was that was my you know fond
memories of underground hey let's talk
about the final point I want to talk
about because it for some reason it's
one of my favorite aspects of this game
and at the start I thought it was like
super kooky and weird but the fact that
this game is it like perpetual night
time it's what we love yeah well the
show underground was was all at night as
well so it's sort of in keeping with
that but it's illegal tradition right
like what illegal street race has
happened in the military p.m. yeah I'm
like bridges not generally i imagine how
those sorts of things are conducted not
really you know I'm not much of a
gearhead I haven't spent a lot of time
we know racing cars cats go yeah and
said it's not racing cars though his
fingers yeah clearly yeah really a tuner
I changes my headlight this weekend this
you're feeling tuned X's you have
impress you indicated
yeah man scream I put actually had to go
back as i bought the wrong one did you
really yeah you didn't change your
headlight you replaced your headline
yeah oh yeah cuz you were there was like
a weight have you been driving around
for like a month I don't drive my car
okay okay only on weekends and during
the day but what I love about the
nighttime stuff is that like it in
certain parts of the map it's like dawn
yeah it starts to get a little dusky and
then it immediately 90mg go gasps like a
point in the level and it goes like
Faden fail yeah so it's like you're
playing in like Alaska or something but
like it's daytime from 30 minutes in
from bagging game like we kind of brush
on how it looks good like the night
driving it looks [ __ ] cool like it's
beautiful the game is absolutely
awareness as well yeah yeah me what
street I get that people think that it's
kind of dumb that it's always wet and
always night but god it's it's gorgeous
I just love whipping around the world
it's just so much fun just to drive
around and look at everything it's
beautiful it's it's one of the best
looking racing games I've ever played
and last point on us and I just want to
touch on before we wrap up multiplayer
stuff how does that work is it essential
is it non-essential like so you're in a
sort of shared open world i mean like i
said you're in a big city it's an open
world map and within that map you will
find other drivers it's it's always
online which is its own its own thing i
called it out in the review because I
knew that for some people that's a
deal-breaker like always unlike note out
and they burn it to the ground I want
nothing to do with it instantly and for
me it wasn't a deal breaker like it's
annoying for the reasons I outline in
the review he can't pause stuff like
that and yet I don't like it but I've
learned to live with it oh yeah that's
why we go to the map yes and your car
just keeps going he went to the map and
the cars just like going down to be nice
and good it's always online you you
can't pause the game like if you need to
did the joke I made in the reviews we
need to stop your cat and just drawing
your furniture you can't you're either
gonna lose the event or your cats going
to destroy your couch it's like you
can't actually pause the game always
online is annoying for a lot of reasons
that's one of them but again for me not
a deal breaker called it out so people
can make up their own minds if they hate
it find great but yes multiplayer you
can create crews and have your friends
join defense with you you can just
cruise around the map and find people
there and challenge them to sort of ad
hoc events by just pulling up next them
and pulling one of the triggers or one
of the bumpers yeah so there are plenty
of options there's no dedicated
multiplayer mode but I didn't have a
problem jumping into events and having
fun with
people actual human beings not rubber
banding AI any benefits of that was it
like extra cash rewards or uh if you
beat a friend's time it'll specifically
mark events where a friend has set a
high score or best time and if you go to
that event and you beat their time you
get more rep experience and more cash
than you would have if it was just
regular available so the game does
reward you for beating your friends
times and playing sort of asynchronously
right so just make sure your friends
suck an eephus be exactly to go sorry
there's no cockpit cam no manual
shifting that's true not a lot of
options which and it's like I'm in
Arcady like need for speed fan I like
the burnout games i like big crash isn't
going fast so stuff like manual shifting
and and cockpit view don't really matter
to me i mentioned a couple of them in
the review just so people would know but
for me I'm just there to go fast like I
don't need shifting it didn't affect me
I don't care um but for some people I
know that that's a deal breaker no no
you can make your own silence readers
good info viewers watchers who ever yeah
so that's need for speed sweet honey
Scott thank you so much I'm still
talking about race cars presumably this
is back to being an honest franchise we
may see you guys will see once let's
talk about all again and let us know
what you think of need for speed you are
a fan of the series you want to get back
into it or is this one piqued your
interest for the first time or Dean are
you not into it you have another racing
game du jour you're enjoying it let us
know in the comment box below all right